schrebergarten das garantiert
verwurzelung im wahrsten sinne kein
gemüse früchte kräuter im ganzen ort auf
schritt und tritt und alles wartet nur
darauf gepflückt und verspiesen zu
werden dies dank einiger pensionierter
frauen mit anarchistisch grünen daumen
die diese wuchernde freigiebig
kritisiert
willkommen in hamborn in diesen geräten
hat vor acht jahren alles angefangen
großen raus gemüse rein und zugang für
alle incredible edible wunderbar lesbar
in etwa so der griffige name der grüne
bewegung mit mary klar an der spitze
das ist also ihr geraten eigentlich
gehört der alm worden
er ist bloß an mein haus angebaut marica
hat den boden geebnet für eine idee die
heute weltweit blüht das ist mangold
wir nennen es charts das lieblingsgemüse
der briten der farbigsten salat den an
garten vergeblich und sie kennen das
nicht schämen sie sich schweizer mensch
am anfang waren viele skeptisch
wir galten als ein haufen verrückter sie
gaben uns höchstens ein jahr
dabei haben wir es weit gebracht es
wurde befürchtet dass gestohlen und
zerstört werde
aber es kam anders mittlerweile hat sich
die bewegung in die ganze welt
ausgebreitet und wir haben entschieden
keine öffentlichen gelder zu
beanspruchen
wir wollen selbst versorgen und
selbsttragend sein
dafür arbeiten alle unentgeltlich jung
und alt auch die hochbeete haben sie
selber hergestellt mancher helferinnen
sind gar extra zugezogen
um an der erfolgsgeschichte mit zu
pflanzen warum sind sie bereit so viel
zeit zu investieren
ich kann hier arbeiten wann es mir passt
ist jemand in den ferien dann kommen
andere und machen die arbeit
es fühlt sich gut an etwas wachsen zu
lassen und der ort sieht heute einfach
schöner aus das macht uns stolz den
leuten gefällt es auf dem heimweg nehmen
sie noch etwas schnittlauch mit zum
anrichten ihrer kartoffeln was hier
heute selbstverständlich ist brauchte im
herzen des gesitteten königreich seine
liebe anlaufzeit
wir hatten die größten probleme die
leute dazu zu bringen sich zu bedienen
es passt nicht zur britischen art stets
kontrolliert nur nehmen was man auch
bezahlt hat dazu noch von einer an sich
unautorisierten bepflanzung
so dauert es fast zwei jahren
das ist letztlich klappte ist ein
ausgewachsener glücksfall für das
städtchen in der region west yorkshire
idyllisch aber auch etwas verschlafen
bis eben der vegetable touristen
einsetzte
nun kommen neugierige besucher aus aller
welt um das grüne wunder zu sehen bis zu
150 touren führt ist hellbraun jedes
jahr
pflanzt plätze finden sich mittlerweile
überall im ort entlang des alten
schifffahrt kanals oder sogar vor der
polizeiwache immer ohne einsatz von
pestiziden und erstaunlicherweise nur
mit stillschweigendem einverständnis
sie hatten nie eine bewilligung nein die
polizei sagte fragt uns bloß nicht dass
sie es für uns los macht einfach die
stadt profitiert in großem maße von
dieser positiv anarchistischen spontan
bestäubung ohne dass dies die
steuerzahler etwas kostet eine
erfolgsgeschichte mit nutzen für die
ganze gemeinschaft unser gemeinsinn
wurde gestärkt
es geht letztlich nicht um gemüse
sondern um großzügigkeit
der kreislauf von geben und nehmen
scheint hier zu funktionieren so gilt er
nicht mehr so viel du kannst sondern so
wie du brauchst und selber etwas grünes
in die welt
tatmorgen die botschaft ist angekommen